welcome to this video playing oops okay
it's it's Donny Tov okay one in Game one
win and I don't remember that game at
all so do we get some Catalan or Queens
i can i can try the Kings Indian attack
for once not a bad opening and leads to
try once in a while why trying to
establish that out that stronghold only
five and try to attack on the kingside
have to keep that pawn & 9 f 1 okay I
know he does that so I'm happy to go to
f3 so let's do the typical attacking
idea I think that this early 94 isn't
that great because because I'm it
hampers more than it helps here's
interesting I can try Bishop takes 25
and this position takes then e6 isn't
that good
I am I giving up too much material I
don't think so let's go ahead I think it
takes f7 and then taking the rook I
don't really see a defense to that maybe
age 6 h-6 a movie f7 Queen f7 is kind of
sting okay so she's giving the Queen so
I can also take f7 now but Queen takes
and it's okay so I'm taking this and now
i'm the queen up form the bishop Pam
Queen h5 I guess or not wait he cannot
take g 5 EA does hanging so f 5 is a
move but if I go Quinn h5 how is he
defending all that f 7 h-7 and the pin
on the e-file not really
black resigned yeah Bishop t5 to be
honest I think that 94 is already not
such a brilliant idea you sometimes see
that idea but it is usually played when
white already has another f1 so in
situations where I'm not ready to bring
this to have three quickly now this is
more of a liability than an asset Bishop
f4 that looks normal e six very slow
rook e8 yeah I know I when I g5
directive directly I'm going for the
throat there the engine is fearless
wants to play h6 now of course I mean I
expected this move but i thought i'm
just going back and I'm happy that I
have something that I can attack later
even simple the Queen d2 bishop age 6 s
not at all harmless okay night f8 yeah
and here I took it ok the engine goes
age six this is a very thing I didn't
think about that whole very sloppy job
yeah ok it seems that after age 694
Teague's e6 I'm kind of okay but it's
funnier like this is doing this and then
not much happens weird but now I'm
winning them say I'm really winning
you know that engine is on plus 12 so
it's always an interesting thing if you
see that plus 12 if you know that if you
let it run for a little bit you'll find
some kind of chick made okay well thanks
for watching